y la histerectomía es la extirpación
quirúrgica del útero
cuando también se extirpan los ovarios y
las trompas de falopio se denomina
histerectomía con salpinguectomía una
histerectomía se realiza con el
propósito de tratar el cáncer del útero
los fibroides uterinos la endometriosis
el prolapso uterino y otras afecciones
ginecológicas
cuando usted llega al hospital para
someterse a la cirugía se le colocará
una vía intravenosa si se le va a
practicar una histerectomía abdominal es
posible que le rasura en la zona púbica
y abdominal
las histerectomía se pueden realizar con
anestesia general o local
si recibe anestesia general estará
dormida durante todo el procedimiento y
se insertará temporalmente un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y en la
garganta para ayudarle a respirar
durante la operación
se le colocará un catéter en la vejiga
para drenar la orina durante la cirugía
una histerectomía dura entre una y tres
horas existen tres formas principales de
hacer esta cirugía por vía abdominal por
vía vaginal
o por vía vaginal asistida con
laparoscopia
para una histerectomía abdominal el
cirujano realizará una incisión en el
abdomen inferior
retirará los músculos para exponer el
útero
cortará los ligamentos y tejidos que
sostienen el útero en su lugar
y extirpar a el útero a través de la
incisión abdominal
si el procedimiento incluye una
salpinguectomía el cirujano extirpar a
los ovarios y las trompas de falopio de
la misma forma
para realizar una histerectomía vaginal
se inserta un espéculo pesado en la
vagina para estirarla y mantenerla
abierta
el cirujano realizará una incisión
interna alrededor del cuello del útero
cortara los ligamentos y tejidos que
sostienen el útero en su lugar
y deslizará el útero por la vagina
para una histerectomía vaginal asistida
con laparoscopia el cirujano creará
varias incisiones pequeñas denominadas
puertos de entrada en el abdomen
luego se bombeará dióxido de carbono a
través del puerto de entrada umbilical
para inflar el abdomen y así poder
visualizar su contenido más fácilmente
el cirujano insertará un laparoscopio
por uno de los puertos las imágenes de
la cámara se proyectan en un monitor de
la sala de operaciones
observando el monitor el cirujano
deslizará herramientas quirúrgicas
especializadas por los otros puertos y
las utilizará para realizar una incisión
alrededor del cuello del útero
liberará al útero de los tejidos y
ligamentos que los sostienen
y lo pasará por la vagina un
laparoscopio también se puede utilizar
para un as al bingo forec tome a
finalmente el cirujano cerrará las
incisiones en el abdomen con puntos
en los tres procedimientos de
histerectomía la parte superior de la
vagina se sutura y se coloca un
taponamiento de gasa en la vagina para
evitar el sangrado en exceso
después de la cirugía se la llevará al
área de recuperación para su monitoreo
el catéter y el taponamiento de gasas se
retirarán antes de que abandone el
hospital